aujourd'hui nous allons découvrir le
dispositif nommé PCH la prestation
compensatrice du handicap permet de
compenser le handicap à travers
plusieurs types de prestations nous
allons le voir
la PCH la prestation compensatrice du
handicap c'était des destinée aux
personnes âgées de moins de 60 ans
reconnu handicapés par la MDPH partons à
la rencontre de Sarah qui bénéficie de
cette aide explique à nous depuis
combien de temps on a un PCH et comment
la PCH est dans d'autres quotidien
depuis 2015 monnaie bénéficiaire de la
PC h et il y a des moyens habits tous
les jours dans mon quotidien et on a
besoin quelqu'un de en permanence
mais quand elle part il faut quelqu'un
toujours pour rester avec moi et donc il
faut il a besoin pour la toilette on a
besoin pour mon déplacement
un peu de tout c'est justement quels
sont les avantages d'avoir une personne
comme ça avec ou dans la lettre PCH les
primordiales d'avoir une personne quand
le handicapée d'être accompagné sur tout
dans la vie tous les jours mamie pense
les les corps même bien le département
la médecin en place mais assez Sarah
mais de rien
le département en tant que chef de fil
de l'action sociale au point un certain
nombre d'aide aux personnes porteuses à
l'handicap parmi ces aides figurent PCH
qui permet de compenser le handicap du
bénéficiaire en lui permettant de se
maintenir à domicile dans quel but a été
créé la PC h alors la PCH est une aide
qui a porté par le département pour
répondre aux besoins liés à la perte
d'autonomie de personnes qui sont
porteuses handicap donc la PCH elle va
pouvoir revêtir plusieurs formes il
pourra par exemple s'agir du nez du
Maine ce sera la possibilité de recourir
à une tierce personne que ce soit un
prestataire ou un aidant familial pour
une assistance totale ou partielle avec
la PCH le département va pouvoir aussi
accorder une aide technique au
bénéficiaire ce sera la possibilité de
se faire financer l'achat ou la location
de matériel le bénéficiaire pourra aussi
se faire accompagner pour aménager son
logement aménager son véhicule et ainsi
les éventuels surcoût liées au transport
seront prises en compte on a aussi des
aides qu'on peut qualifier un petit peu
que de particulière comme les aides
animalières quel est le montant de cette
prestation la PCH est une aide qui est
personnalisée chaque bénéficiaire étant
différent il n'y aura pas de mothentique
merci Tatiana merci maronie
[Musique]
grâce à la prestation compensatrice du
handicap le quotidien des personnes
handicapées et dépendante devient plus
facile quelles sont les démarches à
suivre pour pouvoir bénéficier de la PC
h pour pouvoir bénéficier de la PCH il
faudra faire une demande auprès de la
Maison départementale des personnes
handicapées on peut être aidé pour faire
cette demande par la MDPH ou le CCAS de
sa commune ensuite l'équipe
pluridisciplinaire de la MDPH va évaluer
les besoins de la personne ensuite le
dossier va être présenté à la CDAPH la
commission des droits et de l'autonomie
des personnes handicapées qui prendra
une décision et la personne elle va
recevoir ce qu'on appelle une
notification qui va également être
transmis à l'organisme payeur Laza
l'aide sociale aux adultes qui va
ensuite payer la prestation de
compensation du handicap merci maronie
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine nous irons à Laura
pour rencontrer Madame Morin si tu es au
nord-est de Lille les accueillis de joie
sont destinés à des personnes vivant à
domicile de plus de 60 ans souffrant
d'une maladie type Alzheimer ou aux
personnes atteintes d'une maladie
neurodégénérative en situation de
dépendance physique et ou psychique
[Musique]